-Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Yeah, that feels good, right?
The aud--
-Oh, my goodness.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, oh, my goodness.
You make me feel so special.
Wow!
-You're beloved.
-Oh, my goodness.
-We love you as Ned.
-Oh, thank you, man.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, thank you, guys.
-You're funny. You're natural.
It's so good.
I just wanted to remind you --
I don't know if you know this --
you're in three of the top-10
highest-grossing movies
of all time.
-Whoa!
-Come on, now.
-Of all time.
-That is honestly --
I can't even begin to explain
my excitement
just being on, Jimmy.
I just want to say, I first came
out to the mainland
and I started going to
drama school back in 2015,
near the Flat Iron Building
downtown.
-Yeah.
-And, you know,
being a broke college student,
my friends and I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's 90% of our audience.
-I appreciate you all.
-Yeah, me too.
-The thing that we could afford
to do every day in New York
was to walk
up and down Manhattan.
So, to walk by
this building every day
and just hopefully
one day be on,
and to really
be on today is just --
My mind is --
I'm so, like -- It's insane.
And The Roots --
Like, I literally am such a
big -- I can't even believe
I'm breathing the same air
as you guys.
Like, this is crazy.
Oh, my goodness.
-Now we're family. Come on.
-Oh, I appreciate you.
Thank you, Jimmy. Thank you.
-"Spider-Man: Homecoming"
was only your second movie.
-Yes, for sure.
-That's wild.
-Yeah, some people
just get hella lucky.
I don't know what it is.
-I mean, and how did you
get chemistry with
Tom Holland that fast?
I mean, it feels like you guys
were really
best friends in --
-Yeah, I mean,
I'm very lucky that, you know,
we all sort of started
this journey together.
We were both -- I mean,
we were all 19 at the time.
And, so, you know,
putting a bunch of young kids
together on a movie is maybe not
be the most responsible idea.
But, you know, through that,
through all the
trial and tribulation,
we've sort of just grown
together as, like, a family.
And now every day
is like just family day.
-Yeah. Well, you --
-Yeah.
-You guys were roommates, right?
-Yeah, yeah.
-That's a fast way
to get to know someone.
-Yeah, for sure.
It was like a frat house.
You know, like, a bunch of
19-year-olds
just, like, messing up
and eating a lot of junk food.
Not the best environment,
but the funnest environment
for sure.
-You had to keep one of
the greatest secrets of all time
for "No Way Home."
You were in the scene with
all three Spider-Men.
-Yep, classic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, my --
This is actually really funny.
But my girlfriend --
I had brought her on
to, like, visit work once,
and it was, like,
inadvertently during, like, when
Tobey and Andrew first came.
And I had introduced her to
Tobey, and she was like, "Wait.
Why is this Spider-Man,
like, on your 'Spider-Man'?"
And I was like, "Well, baby,
it's, like, a really big secret,
so maybe don't say nothing."
Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
And she was like --
Like, she's not a big fan,
but she obviously
loves "Spider-Man."
But I think that she
was going to tell her dad
just, like, out of nowhere,
and I had to stop her.
-No.
-But, like, you know, her dad
wasn't going to say anything.
I just feel like she's not
really used to
this world, obviously.
-No.
-Yeah, so, she sat on it
for a year and a half.
She knew the secret
everyone wanted to know. Yeah.
-That's also
a bonding experience.
-Yeah, for sure.
She definitely got to know
them really quick.
-Yeah. Some fans think that your
character may become a villain
somewhere in the Multiverse.
-Uh-huh. Interesting.
You know, I'd just like to say,
I'm really sorry, everyone.
I did this really
stupid thing back in 2016
and mentioned it
in an interview.
And then I stupidly just
continued with the story as if
like I knew
what was going to happen.
And now everyone
is talking about it.
And I just -- I'm sorry for
all the misinformation.
-Wait.
What's the misinformation?
-I mean, like, there's just --
A lot of people like the idea,
and a lot of people
are disgusted by the idea.
So I just feel like I --
Because I'm very much --
I'll do whatever.
You know what I mean? But...
-I mean, clearly, we know that
you love Tom Holland.
You love Spider-Man. Of course.
But a good story
is a good story.
-Yeah.
-Nothing beats a good story.
-It scares me
because "The Tonight Show"
is a big deal,
and if I say something on
"The Tonight Show"...
[ Breathes deeply ]
-Okay, yeah, alright.
Alright, yeah.
But, hey,
if you guys want it enough,
let Marvel know,
and we'll figure something out.
-The fans will do it, you know?
-Yeah, the fans
will make it happen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you want the fans
to watch your new series,
"Reginald the Vampire."
-Yes. Oh, please.
-You star in this.
You executive-produced it.
-Yeah.
-How do you describe this show?
-I would say it's something
that we've absolutely never
put on TV before.
I would say that it's
a very zany and quirky,
but lovable show.
You know, I think that
we have a lot of comparisons
to other shows, but I would say,
you guys just won't
expect what's going to
happen in the show.
-Yeah. It's in the vampire
world, but it's not --
-It's sort of like --
It's watching, like,
a human being go through
all the human things,
like trying to
establish relationships
and finding a friend and finding
your place in the universe,
but all in the backdrop of
becoming a vampire.
So it's a
very normal, human story.
-It's relatable up to a point.
-Absolutely.
-Yeah, and it's fun. Yeah.
-I do want to show
everyone a clip.
Here's Jacob Batalon
in "Reginald the Vampire."
Take a look at this.
-Oh, no.
No.
Vampires are not real.
They're just a story.
-Look, you're a
mother[bleep] vampire, man.
You're -- You're undead.
You can never die...
never grow old.
I mean, you can't die
unless someone
stakes you in the heart
or you get stranded in the sun,
but that's very, very unlikely.
-Can I still eat pizza?
-Yeah, go for it.
You can eat pizza.
-What about ice cream?
-Ice cream, too.
-So my taste buds still taste.
-I think you're putting
a little too much emphasis on
the pizza and
the ice cream right now.
-Yeah, exactly.
Jacob Batalon, everybody.
"Reginald the Vampire" premieres
Wednesday at 10:00 p.m. on Syfy.
We love you, bud.
-Appreciate you, Jimmy.
-Justin Thomas
joins us after the break.
Stick around, everybody!